nato defense ministers met at an
american air base in germany tuesday
discussing more weapons for ukraine
today
canada announced that it will send
ukraine eight armored vehicles canada's
defense minister says that contract was
just finalized and vehicles will be sent
as soon as possible we will continue to
not only send
weapons from the inventory of the
canadian armed forces but we are also
moving to enter into contracts with
defense suppliers
for
weaponry for ukraine
the u.s sending more aid too now up to
3.7 billion dollars ukraine clearly
believes that it can win and so does
everyone here that's quite extraordinary
that you the the nations have come
together that there are no leakers
among the group it's very unlike the
iraq war where there was a lot of
dissent in fact more countries may be
trying to join nato finland and sweden
both with long-standing military
neutrality are mulling a bid to join
nato and as its members meet in germany
the united nations secretary general is
in russia
pushing for ceasefires and humanitarian
corridors out of mariupol i'm concerned
about the repeated reports the
violations of international humanitarian
and human rights law and possible war
crimes
and they require
independent
investigation the un said russian
president vladimir putin agreed in
principle to allowing the u.n and red
cross help evacuate mario paul
while russia's foreign minister raised
the specter of nuclear war on state tv
saying there are serious risks and
dangers it's unhelpful and dangerous to
rattle savers
and speculate
about the use of nuclear weapons a
reminder of the stakes here an
unmistakable warning that russia is
still a nuclear power and that there is
always the possibility of escalation i
take it largely as the same sort of
distorted rhetoric that we've seen
coming out of the russian leadership
sergey lavrov also accused nato of being
engaged in a proxy war meanwhile
canada's defense minister will head here
to washington later this week where
she'll meet u.s defense secretary austin
abigail beeman global news washington